[Music]
these are the moments of which the
reconciliation of spirit with its own
Consciousness proper is composed by
themselves they are single and separate
and it is solely their spiritual Unity
that constitutes the power of this
reconciliation
the last of these moments is however
necessarily this Unity itself and as is
evident it binds them all into itself
the spirit that in its existence is
certain of itself has for the element of
existence nothing else but this
knowledge of itself when it declares
that what it does it does out of a
conviction of Duty this utterance is the
validating of its action action is the
first implicit sundering of the simple
Unity of the notion and the return out
of this dividedness
this first movement changes round into
the second since this element of
recognition posits itself as simple
knowledge of Duty in antithesis to the
distinction and dichotomy that lie in
action as such and so constitute a
stubborn actuality confronting action
but in forgiveness we saw how this
obstinacy surrenders and renounces
itself
here therefore actuality as well as
immediate existence has for
self-consciousness no other significance
than that of being a pure knowing
similarly as determinate existence or as
relation what is self-opposed is a
knowing partly of this purely individual
self partly of knowledge as universal
in this is posited at the same time that
the third moment the universality or
Essence counts only has knowledge for
each of the two sides that stand over
against each other and finally these
latter equally resolve the empty
antithesis still remaining and are the
knowledge of I equals I this individual
self which is immediately a pure knowing
or a universal
paragraphs
793 is bringing all these previous
paragraphs in absolute knowing to a
culmination and what we're going to see
is there's really two different things
going on in this paragraph We could say
that really there's there's uh just a
few lines that are the first thing which
concerns all these previous paragraphs
and what's been going on in them and
then we launch into what seems to be
in some respects
a new dialectical progression but it's
not a new dialectical progression
because What's Happening Here
is we're continuing in absolute knowing
to review what has happened with the
previous development of the shapes of
Consciousness whatever we want to call
them you know earlier sections sections
is kind of a formal way of thinking
about it if we want to think about what
the material or content the in halt is
it's these very complicated dialectical
progressions many of which you know
follow upon each other and sometimes
refer back to each other is something we
talked about in just the previous
paragraph
so let's start at the start we have as
he says
this reconciliation of spirit right so
fair zunong a coming back together this
is an important term for Hegel
particularly if we think about it as
core relative to
conflict to being placed over and
against each other
or to enfandong to alienation or
being made
foreign to each other right and it's
also a matter of dealing with these
splittings or distinctions so
reconciliation is going to be important
and what what is the reconciliation here
he talks about reconciliation of spirit
so far so good it's a phenomenology of
spirit with what with its own
Consciousness
proper eigen leaking so
Spirit at each stage at each
development
has a particular Consciousness and you
know we're playing kind of fast and
loose with the terminology here as is
Hegel himself because consciousness of
course names one of the earliest
portions of the phenomenology but it's
not going away this is a a term that
Hegel is employing over and over again
and it's just getting more and more
complicated
so what's going on all of the stuff that
we've been charting out in the previous
paragraphs of absolute knowing has
referred to what he's calling moments
momentum moments of this reconciliation
so you know looking at it you could say
progressively going through the
phenomenology as we have been doing in
this entire commentary and as people do
when they typically read through the
whole text instead of just excerpting
out the popular Parts but it really work
their way through we begin with
Consciousness and then we go into
self-consciousness a shorter section
then we go into this massive reason
section an even larger Spirit section
and finally culminate in religion which
we've just finished up with before
getting into absolute knowing and each
of these has a whole bunch of sub
moments many of which we have charted
out in an earlier paragraph we looked at
the three different portions of
consciousness
you know we talked about little bits of
self-consciousness with reason we got a
little bit more selective we saw that
there was this discussion of observing
reason then turned inward on the human
being and we've got the uh phrenology
and physiognomy section and then a few
other bits and pieces of reason then we
get to Spirit and we're not looking at
all of spirit in our summary of it but
just you know just parts of it and then
you know we didn't actually dwell that
much on the religion part but it belongs
there
so this raises a very interesting
question
before we get to the very interesting
reveal that's happening here it says by
themselves they're single and separate
it's solely their spiritual Unity that
constitutes the power of this
reconciliation so
when we read the phenomenology and again
I I just mentioned a little bit earlier
the mistake of just focusing in on
isolated sections and saying oh this is
so cool you know what are the the
culprits for that Master Slave dialectic
and then not paying attention to the
rest of self-consciousness including the
much larger stoicism skepticism on Happy
Consciousness that follows the
discussion of the laws of the city and
the laws of the family or the gods that
replicates what's going on in the
Antigone early on in the spirit section
the physiognomy and and phrenology
section in the reason portion of the
work any one of these is it can be an
isolated moment right and they're cool
by themselves there's a lot of
interesting stuff we could dwell on but
Hegel is making the point here that if
you want to see their larger meaning if
you want to see their scope if you want
to see what they actually tell us it's
got to be
within this more comprehensive framework
where they can be
reconciled with each other in spirit for
us the phenomenologists but also the
inheritors of the cultural intellectual
Spiritual Development that has taken
place as Consciousness has traversed all
these sections right and often
retraversed them so by themselves are
single and separate
um it's the spiritual Unity of them and
you know don't think of spirit in any
sort of woo-woo way think of it as we
are the thinkers who have grasped this
Hegel is the Thinker who you know
presumes that he has figured out the key
to the development of human
consciousness through history up to his
point okay so that's already quite a bit
then he says something really cool and
this is where we're going to start
transitioning into the second part
the last of these moments is however
necessarily this Unity itself and as is
evident it binds them all into itself
okay so what is the last of these
moments
is it the religion section no it's the
very section that we're in absolute
knowing so that is sort of coming back
upon itself the reconciliation is
possible because we're done we've
reached the endpoint of our dialectical
struggles and studies and you know all
of this sort of stuff and I do want to
pause here just for a second on thinking
about something so these these moments
should we take
what Hegel has chosen to highlight for
us as being
the most important moments of this
progression as I pointed out he isn't
actually talking about everything that's
going on in self-consciousness or reason
or Spirit he's not even mentioning
religion as such in this but all of
these were important to go through
there's nothing in the phenomenology as
far as we know that Hegel afterwards was
you know going to say oh you know that
was a blind alley it doesn't really
matter for the development of human
consciousness no it all matters it's all
relevant
so I think we have to actually read the
whole of the phenomenology into this
this reconciliation of spirit with its
own Consciousness now how does this take
place
here's where it can get a little bit
tricky because Hegel keeps talking about
firsts and seconds and finally thirds
and stuff like that and so we have to be
a little bit attentive to what he's
actually doing so he begins by saying
um the last of these moments the unity
itself the spirit that in its existence
in its design
is certain of itself right so spirit
that knows itself as what it is it's
overcome the
um alienation of itself from itself it
now has a solid grasp so he says the
spirit that is certain of itself has for
the element of existence nothing else
but this knowledge of itself and that
might make you think about like
Aristotle's idea of uh thought thinking
itself and Hegel actually referenced
that at early on in the preface so you
might be like oh I see we're back to
idealism now what we've got here is a
thought that is managed to isolate and
to free itself of all of the other stuff
the detritus that that's going on the
real world and it can focus solely on
its abstraction and making sense out of
this great history that it's involved in
and so there's there's something to that
but notice what he's going to say here
he's not saying that is the totality of
the spirit that is certain of itself in
existence rather this is it has for the
elements of existence nothing else but
this knowledge of itself it has all
sorts of other things right and this
knowledge of itself we should be careful
in assuming that knowledge of itself is
merely some sort of reflexive abstract
understanding there's more going on here
so what does he do he says it declares
that what it does it does out of a
conviction
right having been convinced
of Duty flicked and you might say how
the hell did we get to duty
I mean isn't that way back in the spirit
and the reason section what what the
hell's going on here uh well Hegel is an
idealist but he is a idealist who
understands the importance of the real
and the Practical right we are what we
are through
action through handle and so even the
very abstract you know Spirit thinking
itself has to declare has to speak
Australian
speak about its action it has to take a
stance on itself an action is by its
very nature something that Roots us
something that individuates us as well I
mean there can be Universal action but
it's individual actors that do things so
he goes on and he says
action well actually I want to bring up
one other thing
um what it does out of a conviction of
Duty this utterance is the validating
the gelton right the giving value to its
action and now we come to action action
he says is the first implicit on
zigzayanda right so the anzique implicit
sundering training it's split it
splitting things apart of what
of the simple Unity of the notion okay
so you know something again abstract the
simple Unity of the notion or we could
even jump ahead and say something
Universal
and the return out of this dividedness
and the the term that's being translated
there by Miller is dividedness is the
same term as he's translated as
sundering a tenen right a splitting
so he says the first movement
now here's where it gets tricky right
the first movement
changes round into the second now what's
he referring to this is where I think
actually we can say both
so
first movement could be this first thing
Spirit certain of itself and then action
and it's splitting
it could also be the two things that
have been divided apart from each other
in action simple Unity of the notion and
return out of dividedness and I don't
think we actually have to choose between
the two because I think they actually
make sense understanding them together
in this way right this is where we have
what we could call productive or perhaps
even intentional
ambiguity so action uh is got these two
you know parts to it the first movement
changes round into the second why the
elements of recognition now that's
important right on air cannon
where have we seen this before well
from self-consciousness on
this is what self-consciousness desires
it hungers for recognition and it's been
trying to get that it's been trying to
give and get this the entire time that
the dialectic has been going on and this
is incredibly important because
we didn't get a good recognition in the
self-consciousness section certainly not
with the Master Slave dialectic right
Master can't get the recognition that
they desire from the slave because the
slave isn't being treated as a full
person and we go through these others
and we get more complicated types of
recognition we also you know can bring
in the notion of God and you know being
part of a relationship with God in which
we recognize God God recognizes us
we've been looking for this in action
the entire time
so he says that
this element of recognition posits
itself as simple knowledge of Duty
in antithesis opposed to the distinction
and dichotomy that lie in action as such
and so constitute a stubborn actuality
confronting action now this is a
reference back to what is happening and
implicitly in the reason section
particularly when we're looking at the
last two portions of it
um you know especially the reason giving
itself laws but even more so in the
spirit section in the morality portion
where we're looking at a very detailed
uh dialectical examination of what goes
into action and can any action be truly
entirely totally good or fulfilled Duty
the way it ought to and the answer for
Hegel was no no it can't there's always
something some vantage point from which
we can look at action handle not just
acting you know doing something but
doing some something intentionally with
a comportment
that somehow the parts don't align
properly and we're looking for a
Reconciliation of this so he talks about
this stubborn actuality right heart this
is something that's hard actuality is
vehicle kite and then he said in
forgiveness we saw how this obstinacy
and quite literally just hardness
surrenders and renounces itself
so he goes on and he says then
actuality as well as immediate existence
Okay so we've got the actuality on the
part of action we've got immediate
existence in spirit that is certain of
itself in the element of existence which
declares about its action both of these
um
have no other significance than that of
being a pure knowing
now that should bring us up short
we should say wait a second
what we just talked about action how the
hell does that turn into a pure knowing
here is where we want to think about
what pure means for Hegel
does it mean something like purified of
any actuality whatsoever any reality any
vehicle kites
any of the complex
splits that have taken place because
those splits
they happen I mean they can be
reconciled they can be forgiven they can
all sorts of things the unity can be
brought to them but they do
exist they do
assert themselves they have their own
design
don't they
so he goes on and he says
um similarly
as determinate existence right existence
that is no longer just something
abstract determinate determined
existence or as even more important
relation
right so we've got determinate
existence we've got relation you know
connectedness to other things nothing is
and this is something we saw in the
dialectic of action right nothing is
purely itself it can be framed it can be
expressed as purely itself
but it's not purely itself so the pure
knowing
is also
acting
not purely but from a standpoint
right so he goes on and says the
determinate existence or as a relation
what is self-opposed is a knowing what
is it knowing
well
it's a knowing of the purely individual
self right so so who's doing this
knowing every single one of us
as we're engaged in action as we
understand ourselves as rooted within
context as deciding things within a
world that already has valuations where
we have to sort of make our way and we
have to revise our action over time and
we've got this entire messy complex
stuff but we're also at the same time
every single one of us
spirit in its universality right
knowledge as he's going to say Universal
all again minor right and so you know
we're partly this partly that and it
goes on and he says in this
is posited at the same time that the
third moment what is the third moment
the universality or Essence counts only
as knowledge for each of the two sides
that stand over against each other so
the third moment exists for the other
things that are standing in relation to
each other all of this matters right all
of this is rolled into this third moment
the the universal and he says finally
these latter equally resolve the empty
antithesis still remaining what is this
empty antithesis still remaining well
what is the I he says they are the
knowledge of I equals I this individual
self which is immediately a pure knowing
or Universal and this is something that
confronts us as human beings all the
time when we're trying to figure out who
the hell are we and what is the meaning
of our existence our life our action our
relationships with other people our
place in a long history that has shaped
us and conditioned us but has not
completely determined us in our present
moment this is some really heady stuff
if we unpack it and that's part of what
Hegel is trying to get us to do trying
to get us to see as we go through this
absolute knowing section so this is how
he is at this point wrapping up the
previous discussions that have been
going on all of this reconciliation of
spirit with its own Consciousness all
this stuff that we've we've had to
remember
to go back to a previous paragraph all
of that is getting rolled into now this
needing to figure out all right what are
my duties or we could frame it in other
moral theoretic terms if we want to as
well what makes me a good person what is
the project of my life and how is it
connected with
others here's where we'll end in terms
not just as some sort of reconciliation
not just some sort of you know
equilibrium with them but a genuine
recognition of the other
and the other of me as human we can do
this with ourselves and we can think
about
how we would bring Hegel himself
into this this very process and all of
human development and history up until
this point has been preparing the way
for us from hegel's time onward to carry
this out